sprechen wir jetzt mit rabbiner yehuda
teichtal er selbst ist 2009/10 opfer
eines antisemitischen anschlags geworden
herr teichtal herzlich willkommen bei
bild an diesem abend
sagen sie uns ist das leben für juden in
deutschland gefährlicher geworden
leider ja es ist in den letzten paar
jahre gefördert worden
ich bin seit 24 jahren hier kabine von
berlin und die letzten zeit ist es
tatsächlich gefährliche warum aus ihrer
sicht was muss passieren um
antisemitismus einzudämmen man hat das
gefühl antisemitismus breitet sich vor
allem in der mitte der gesellschaft so
gefährlich aus anteilnahme nicht
ausreichend
immer wenn es eine anti semitischen tag
passiert heute gibt es nachher große
anteilnahme ich gesendet nach viatag auf
mehr
beim besuch von bundespräsident vor
einem jahr
jetzt muss taten folgen muss vielmehr
auf der ebene der gesellschaft und auf
die ebene die politik stattfinden damit
präventiv konkreten maßnahmen und
konsequenzen ausgeführt sind
welche maßnahmen und konsequenzen
könnten das denn ihrer meinung nach sein
es müssen auf drei engeln einmal auf die
politische ebene für sachliche und
konsequenter wenn eine tat passiert
nicht nur einer auf streit sondern das
muss tatsächlich konsequenzen passieren
zweitens muss für früher erkennt werden
unterschwellige anderes damit geschieht
tendenzen in die bildungs- und
erziehungssystem musst du früher
angegriffen werden und beobachtet und
tatsächlich umgesetzt werden nummer 3
auf die gesellschaftlichen ebene
jeder muss wissen niemanden dass
aufstände wir sind alle davon betroffen
eine attacke auf eine jude ist eine
attacke auf uns allen die die demokratie
und die demokratischen gesellschaft
respektieren
nur wenn die menschen vertrauen haben
werden nur in die jüdische gemeinschaft
betragen haben kann die gesellschaft
dann wird es einen langfristigen
dauerhaften postiven jüdisches leben in
deutschland gesichert so klare
forderungen von yehuda teichtal ganz
herzlichen dank dafür
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren